[Music]
this story takes place here in my
bedroom at home but in 2011 it's the
same I haven't I haven't changed it
since then
I remember super clearly being here one
evening and being on my laptop and going
on YouTube and I only had a YouTube
account for like a year at this point I
still really new to it and I was
recommended a video this video I think
this was the first thing of Minecraft
I've seen apart from somebody recreating
the enterprise in creative mode this was
the first time that I'd seen people like
playing Minecraft and not only was I
kind of hooked by the game I was hooked
by the two people playing it like a
device they were like Laurel and Hardy
one was actually kind of in charge knew
what they were doing and the other one
was kind of clowning around I
immediately knew that I liked what I saw
and I subscribed and I have been
subscribed to the aux cast ever since
this behind me is Queen Square in
Bristol the O's cast have been based in
Bristol for years and they have some
secret Studios an undisclosed location
somewhere but they move recently they
moved about a year ago and I recognise
this square out of the their windows
because I don't restore my life and I
remember coming here a couple of months
ago and I was just like trying to trying
to work out from their videos where they
were based it turned out they were based
in a set of buildings over on this side
I tweeted at the CEO saying we know at
last side the Studios don't worry I'm
not gonna say where it is but I was just
like oh it was kind of cool to see
whether the Studios work i've got
reflecting the CEO saying mate it's
public address
prompt and slightly awkward interaction
though they said you know next time
around come pop in and I will ended up
talking and we actually ended up talking
about doing a video together just why
I'm here today to do some filming with
members of the aux cast to sound excited
is a massive massive understatement I've
just noticed by the way it was a guy
they're doing exactly what I'm doing
I kind of would have talked about waste
building but i'm too socially awkward so
that was me i was waiting outside the
studios i was like a bit early so I was
just kind of hanging out Barry he's one
of the guys whose life's changed me his
content and stuff comes out and sees me
and I was like oh my god I could play it
cool and he kind of comes around in
front of me it's like wait you're them
you know the physics guy from Yuchi
you're Simon ah yeah
[Music]
I'm in the inner sanctum of the artist
cast at the moment I defy bowels to show
you around like this all these deaths
people working hard and I'm here with
the man who's often working hard oh yeah
this is Chris trot hello
so you are one third of hat films yep
the better third the benefi the best
thank you I've been watching hat films
for six years
that's a long time like a very very
scarcely a day goes by where I don't
watch hat films there's a six-year-old
crawling around this as old as you have
watched at films if it heard everything
I've heard mmm
then it's a pretty messed up special
there's out the other half there's like
30 or 40 people here making videos and I
just been chance people have enchants
people over I've been watching about
what it's like to be a youtuber what my
plan is what the plan for the studio's
here are and also working together on
videos terms of the guy that invited me
here and hopefully we're gonna be doing
some filming yes in future soon
hopefully
so stay tuned
unless you put this on after in which
case we've never been definitely watch
it so we didn't actually shoot anything
today for this collab but turps is the
CEO the whole thing has basically said
right yeah I want you to do this collab
with these people I think they'd be
really great including like Simon B of V
Simon from the almost cast when I was
expecting at all but basically people
here seem really really keen and excited
to do some stuff together which is like
it's like a dream come true honestly so
it's been really cool we've just been
Blake a Chan to to try it and also to
Ross over there about basically as this
individual youtuber I don't get to talk
to other youtubers at all so it's really
cool to come in and be like yeah none of
us know what we're doing basically when
it comes to you know saying why did my
video do well and everyone's like yeah
up to the YouTube gods the algorithm
yeah it is so there is no one way of
doing anything yeah and you know we're
not doing it right yeah yeah
but however it's always great to talk to
other people sharing that experience so
it's good that you came here yeah
honestly I've had such a fun time just
like kind of also from a family
perspective just being like oh my god
all these people and everything's about
yeah well you guys had what semester yes
we have which I couldn't believe on a
stream you are like very professional
very well-spoken thank you very nice the
editors I'm here with the space-boat
King hey this is Ben Ben does one of my
favorite streams which is Luis and
Venice April though I'll leave a link
down there we've just been chatting
about the stuff behind us yeah what
house
because I did really works at Games
Workshop I did yeah yeah a long time ago
now over ten years ago
I'm just working at Nottingham because
like you were he works at Games Workshop
and then you became a youtuber which is
my kind of childhoods ideal career I
have boring jobs in between those it's
not a seamless you know no tries to
nerds I'm in Clark
oh hey it's Simon Clark I recognize his
name from our previous XCOM and he was
incredibly lovely man he was he was
great he was he was I couldn't believe
you he's very happy to be oh what the
[ __ ]
and the man himself this is
let mr. Lewis Brinsley welcome Simon
Clarke to your tailors thank you it's
been it's been honestly amazing like
coming here is like I've already said it
in the blog like it's like a playground
yes like a kids playground with toys and
games and there's a craze going around
whatever it is always a crazy like
Warhammer is definitely big in at the
moment it was it was card star was
destiny cards it was Pokemon it was it
was yo-yos pogs
beyblade really yep beyblade never wore
into beyblade come back because I've got
an extensive not bein blades those are
very different those of Warhammer those
are very big Jess that's what Tom's like
every time I buy anything can you pick
me up a bangle 800 quid yeah well I've
been watching you since 2011 so it's
been kind of amazing to meet everybody
and hopefully work on a video I might be
doing something to sign on
yeah I'm still processing everything
that happened yesterday like well that
was a weird dream I had in case they
didn't say it enough yesterday I had the
best time it was one of happiest days
I've had it in a long long time and be
able to meet basically like YouTube
heroes you know but also being able to
see behind the scenes and not having it
ruin the magic like they're just the
same people as the in real life as they
are on videos literally the only
difference is there's a camera rolling
there was so genuine it's so lovely and
it was so great to see the community the
social aspects all these people making
stuff and talking to each other and it's
something that me working here on my own
I kind of lack it's something that
eventually I'd love to set up at a
similar office for science science
purposes but you know it was just so
great I loved it
[Music]